a
そろそろスーツに飽きてきましたまず店トレスというわけでみなさん私の今の生活どう
なっているがご存知でしょうか
興味がない興味がなくても今日は話させていただきますよね私肇社長今ですねどういう
状態になっているかといいますと
まあ
社長7客を見えて
本文などへホームなら社長なんですけどもやっぱり昔やってた時ってこんな日で動画
とって一人でワイワイガヤガヤ楽しくやってたのが昔のスタイルだったんですけども
おかげさまでいろいろ忙しくなってきましてその時間がないと一人でやる時間がないと
なると次どういうステップになるかというと他の人と協力して動画を作るという形に
なってきたわけなんですよいまで最近
あとなんかそのグループユーチューバーの舞彼らが見てると
以上をもってあの肇社長の畑もやらせていただいておりまして昔住んでは僕の家初めは
みゅーずめんとファーグ発布を畑の撮影スタジオとして今厚川で使ってるんですけど
そしてかくいうワタクシはじめ撮影のメインチャンネルをどこで取るかと言いますと
あのこちらの隣の家で今とっております
ですが畑をつくって私は思ってしまったよう提訴がすくなってしまったと
でも後悔はしてないんで全然畑も楽しい指名も楽しいし全然いいんですけどもこんなに
やることいっぱいになってどうやって乗り切ればいいのかっていうと結局ですねもっと
人を増やすしかないということに至ったんですよね走る必要な敵をはじめ社長の畑で
あのたくさんの人で撮影と姫
言うとかやってもらってるんですけどあれこれをれ結局忙しくなっただけじゃねって
いうことで実はこんな感じで船長のメインチャンネルも撮影とか編集をちょっと手伝っ
てもらえる人とかスタッフも増えてですねまあいわば肇社長の端型チームとはじめ冊を
のメインチャンネルチームという2つに別れて今動画を撮っておりますあっつの部屋と
骨の家で
えっマネが大事なことがなくなっているそれは何か
私の1人の場所そうなんです皆さん実は僕こう見えて一人が好きなんですよ
畑が始まって骨の部屋に来たねあの一人の時はよかったんですけどこっちもスタッフが
増えるといよいよ僕が2人になる瞬間がなくなっちゃってなんか僕動画データとか思っ
てくるって結構一人の時が多いんですよ唯じゃあも叩ける人がいっぱいベンチもここに
人がよくいる
[音楽]
y フィ釣りになれやということでですねあの実話なんですけども
もう一人は借りておりましたーーー
最近なんですけどそれを今日初で公開しようと思います住所とが下がらないでください
プライベートなんでプライベート
じゃあゾーンに住んだって
確かでもいいね相撲た曲より堂々としてた方がいいと思うんですへは行ってみよ
はいというわけでさっそくやってまいりましたここが私の
何これぞ日に12東京に1
田山につい
実家
6個目ですこれ私の6個日の家になりますでは
どうぞその中最近入ったわけではないんですけどなんか彼がボツボツ多いで悪くない
ですねはいお客さん用のスリッパとちゃんとくまさんのね
この船を言いの中この足置き場
おいてあります付ですごくでもいきなり色はなんですよ開けてみますね
[音楽]
何かとにはそのようなもやっぱり時でだいたい生活てきたな家具が置いてあるじゃない
ですね
コネがいろいろ物を置いて
でかいテレビを置いてくれステ4てなんか無駄にねあの女の子出雲来ていいように照明
と恐れなラグマット一緒にそれをのソが置いてありますねはいというのがここが多分
リビングですねそんなに大きくないんですけどまぁ一人で生活する分にはいいかなって
感じでございますそしてこの部屋の一番の見どころはこちら
キッチンですこのゲッティすごい
ではですねここでごキッチントントンするんですけどもカメラをここにおけばですね
こうあの料理道具だと取れる気がする
ここに冷蔵庫とが怒られるんですけど二期はありません多分なんか領域とするとここに
なるのかなという気はしておりますそしてここが寝室になりますねここでたくさんの女
の
だったはいというわけでこちらが第6のうちになります
どんなピボット年って思われると思うんですけども本当にどんだけ持ってんだって僕も
持ってます
ただあの静岡なね決してそんなめちゃくちゃ高い物件ではないのであの皆さん安心して
ください
ただいま賃貸がごくあるって5個全部足すとそこそこの金額にはなれ
んですけどまぁなんでこのいいを借りたかというとその女の子連れプライベードの時間
がとても大事だねっていう話をいろんな人としまして
まあカットはもちろん叩ける人がいるでメインもスタッフさんがいる
なるとさすがに僕もは一人でいたいなと実はですねあーちゃんとしたベッドがそこが
なくて最近ずっと人をダメにするソファ度は出てたんですよそれがですねあそこが
ベッドで寝るように
なったりしっかり休んだりあのしっかり一人でいる時をがお部屋っていうイメージで
ございますまぁでもあの料理動画とか出すとそこも話は変わってくるんですけどあのう
仕事とプライベートを分けることを結構大事ですよ
つってもほぼプライベートだ長瀬みたいなもんなんですけどとかも流してた時間の使い
方ですね撮影管理でよる骨児童が休めたり色々ネタを考えることもできるかも死んだり
して例えばでしょアンチとかね
強い人が家に来て実際あったんですよストーカー事件とかそういう時にもう場所が完全
にわかって言ったら結構危険だと思ったんではまずやはり時の避難場所とかとしてノー
この部屋は使って
いただきたいと思っております入っていう感じの6個目のお部屋になります
まあこれでも皆さんにも言っちゃったんで全然ないがこの後動画とかで出てくるかも
しれないけどあの一応紹介しておかないと1何なんだろうとなると思うんで紹介させて
いただきました
これで6個名
[音楽]
ええええええ
me
バッハ